alright let's focus on some chests I'm
probably gonna come out all of that for
YouTube but for the YouTube people you
should check out Karen ATL chess club on
Twitch she's on the verge of breaking
950 followers and then we'll be on the
verge of breaking a thousand followers
and shout out to people Last Samurai
still in the chats GM done Feingold in
the chats say no to drugs Eric
yeah but not caffeine or at least not
like caffeinated tea something I can't
say no to anyway I'm gonna show my game
against Keaton Kara well and for the
YouTube people all have already posted
my preparation I did a lot of
preparation for this game and then he
slightly surprised me in the opening so
the preparation wasn't so useful but now
I still got a nice position
I play d4 expecting Sicilian which he
played I played Knight c3 and here I was
expecting a 6 I was most expecting a 6
I was also may be anticipating knight c6
if knight c6 I was going to play some
interesting line like there should be 5
and then Knight of 3 so a trendy thing
these days and then a6 there's a really
interesting line to start out with like
a closed Sicilian and then let's lay
Bishop g2 Bishop e7 yada yada and I was
preparing for b4 here but just to share
another possible line here which for
anyone who plays Knight c3 on move to
against the Sicilian there's a really
interesting idea if if black plays d5
white can play f5 not the most common
move but very high-scoring and it
actually leads to a possible pea
sacrifice after a d4 pawn takes pawn
light can sack the Knights and then take
on f7 and the computer actually favors
this position for whites there's been
some games here
just a couple games the first time I
ever like encountered this line I
actually played the black side this was
back in the ICC days I just got crushed
and then I checked with the engine it's
apparently good for whites
so anyway going back we didn't go into
any of that cat6 i still play g3 and
then i was half expecting him to still
go for the set up like early queenside
expansion but ok he played sort of a
time on of set it up like knight c6
Knight f6 so very standard sort of
development and then I wanted to be
flexible maybe I could have played d4
here it's most common move I wasn't sure
whether I want to play d4 or treat it as
a closest iliyan and play d3 and later
f4 so I played what I thought is a
useful move here at pawn h3 which maybe
in hindsight isn't so useful but there's
so many cases where my dish it comes to
e3 and I don't want to deal with Knight
g4 so that's what happened
he played d6 and then I played d4 so
started as a closed Sicilian but now
it's an open Sicilian basically a
feeding cattle variation what I tracking
thing oh the eye tracking thing wait can
I turn it on oh now you now you see what
I'm looking at yeah I'm not gonna have
it on for at least for this game review
I think it would be way too distracting
I'm gonna try and keep this instructive
- I'm only gonna use it when like the
time is right so ok Queen c7 Bishop e3
then a6 and this is the first moment I
was maybe talk I took like somewhat of a
longer thing and I play the move which
transforms the structure a little bit
I mean the maybe the normal thing to do
here is play a four and then later night
be three and eventually do stuff on the
kingside but I play the move here Knight
takes c6 and this is an idea that I've
I've seen before I've encountered as
black I've actually taught this idea to
students from the white side and it's
it's interesting because at first it
looks like I'm just strengthening black
Center but the idea for a wide is to
play 9 a 4 B 6 is somewhat of a target
and then white wants to play c4 b3 and
just have a nice combined in the center
and that's essentially what happened
played rugby eights played c4 c5 b3 and
it's a very pleasant sort of structure
where black can almost never play d5 my
knight will return to c3 and I want to
apply pressure to the D file so the game
continued playing positionally now in
this position I should have recognized
blacks plan when he plays my d7 the idea
is to play Knight e5 to c6 and I was
moving quickly I wanted to like not get
too low on time and keep the pace I
quickly played Queen c2 I should have
played f4 just stopped the night the
night is a little bit awkward if it
wants to get to c6 he has to play like
this and then this and then this and
just takes a little bit more time but ok
I allow 95 I was still feeling very
comfortable and then I play 92 so after
Bishop f6 Black has a sort of a
positional threats black wants to play
Bishop d4 force a trade of dark squared
Bishop sand then play Knight d4 so 92
just prevents this
rookie eights and then I play G for
delayed Grob controlling more space and
maybe thinking about the majestic g5
because I wanted to I wanted to keep my
options open also had ideas of Knight g3
9 h5 so he played g6 I think this is a
reasonable response love HS get ready
for it
are you ready yeah ready g5 hitting the
bishop gaining space the bishop moves
back
honestly g5 wasn't the most like
jaw-dropping move but it was g5 and now
I'm controlling more squares and then I
play h4 so yeah because of the
tournament situation I just wanted to
throw pawns and eventually whoa it's
bits
had to wait all tournament was this my
only time playing g5 the whole
tournament yeah this is my first g5 all
tournament man okay not that it like
matters in terms of like chess
importance it's just a move just a pawn
move but it is bits
thanks for the bits
so let's hide notation from people and
then he plays a5 so he's basically
calling my bluff that like my pawns are
not as scary as they seem and he wants
to like to his own thing on the
queenside
and there's some reasonable idea like a
4 and move the bishop and pressure b3 or
maybe even like open the a file and play
rock edge because I don't have access to
a 1 so I play Queen d2 with idea that
his rook now needs to defend this pawn
so yeah d6 is weak it's somewhat
backwards because I'm controlling the
square and then I play h5 so I keep
throwing pawns the thing is it's still
hard to break through because the
structure is so solid but I want to open
up some lines you play safe or maybe
this is a good question for the chat
because this is actually a somewhat
critical moment White has a few ideas
here I will say that I I made a mistake
in this position but I want to see what
the chat would play so chat feel free
suggest any move or idea or plan for
whites and we'll see at what people
suggest and we'll see how many people
played the move that I play and how many
people will maybe suggest the best
response
okay so already we have a few
suggestions we have pawn takes pawn
we have h6 we have Knight g3 definitely
Knight g3 says nate shadow theme h h6 h
6h 6 q 6 Bishop f3 that's a new move sac
the Queen botas gambits there's multiple
ways to staff the Queen
monk born suggesting f5 three-in-a-row
B takes a free pawn writes a lot of
moves here
a5 that's a new move okay um let's get
rid of Queen d6 like all of these moves
maybe have some ideas Queen G eights
slightly illegal so the move I played
was actually one of the worst moves out
of all the moves suggested I played f5 I
think the only other person to suggest
that Oh a few people suggested it I will
shock and monk born this is not a so
this looks like so enterprising and like
when I play that I thought oh man he's
he's under fire I'm gonna like open the
file or or get f6 in and I was feeling
good and then he played his next move
and then I was feeling really bad so
real quickly I'll I'll say that like
after the game I was interviewed by
Lenderman and Lenderman was saying h6 is
best
I think he was using some engine
assistance shutting down some tension
but then going for a very positional
play rather than focusing on the Kings
side
he was suggesting Knight c3 and Knight
b5 which is an idea I completely
neglected so but the issue is with f5
happen the game is that I'm I'm just
overextending and blackouts counterpunch
and after he took on a5 I my original
intention was to take back but if I take
back
there's Queen e7 and then I'm actually
the one getting attacked and it wasn't
wasn't going to be pleasant now there
was an idea here which I I failed so
like recognize how strong it could have
been during the game I'm not entirely
sure of the exact evaluation
but if I allowed this I could have taken
on g6 he would take takes takes so I go
down at Bishop but then I take on f7
it's just a whole mess like cuz the
bishops attacked I had pawns in his face
Bishop d5 on the horizon this would have
been really interesting like rook take
c2 maybe just where it takes b7 Bishop
d5 still looming and the night hanging
no idea what's going on here but I play
the move which I thought gave me better
chances I played nine F for failing also
to see his next move or at least the
strength of his next move Knight e4 and
this is where my position just starts to
crumble because I have nothing like I
wanted to play Knight e5 and kick his
queen and exploit that six but he just
takes it and meanwhile there's so much
pressure on the e-file my King begins to
lack shelter and then they got really
bad
I took he took this mind is so strong
hitting my bishop I played Bishop f2 he
takes I take if I take with king he has
this move hitting the pawn and
threatening this check would be really
really difficult to deal with so I took
with Knights
it's so sad like I have no pawns to
defend my king so I have to defend my
king with minor pieces I was not in time
pressure at this point I had a lot of
time when I played out 5 I still had
maybe like 25 30 minutes around this
point he took on b3 and then he plays
Queen d7 and I'm already down the pawn
I have no attack his pieces are better
than mine this is attacked i play Queen
d3
and there's a lot of ideas here for
black rookie for was strong ideas of
this and just meeting me so I take I
take on c5 and actually maybe he missed
Bishop takes e5 it still worked out well
for him he still manages to be up a pawn
to rook G for Queen a3 takes takes and
then takes and he still has these three
kings i pawns so I take here then there
is some weird line where he could play
and he like what happened in the game
after I took on g6 he and me they took
back without even thinking so I think he
maybe missed a small chance to play
Knight h4 however I don't think this
fully works even though 9h four attacks
three things attacks the rook the knight
and the bishop I think I have some
annoying threats like check if the King
moves to f8 I can take with check and he
has to give some material oh wait no he
takes us wait a minute this is just
winning for luck
I have work f2 here I think work f2
probably keeps me alive because if he
takes us right away then I win the night
and if he takes on g2 then I can
interpose with check this is still
probably okay for white and then if he
plays King h8 still everything hanging I
would have f8 queen takes an Bishop t4 I
saved my bishop and then rook f2 will
save everything else so we got to this
position I'm clearly worse I'd know any
chances at this points I'm just trying
to hold on for dear life
and there's still I mean from my
perspective there's still money on the
line like even though okay I'm most
likely to lose or draw the difference
between losing and drawing is like at
least a couple hundred dollars so there
is still motivation for me to like try
and fight so I play rook p1 this is a
passed pawn I wanted I was dreaming of
like pushing this and someday Queenie
Bishop e5 I play King f1 getting out of
the pin rook g4 and rook d1 yeah rook
g4s threatening to take the c4 pawn what
should be explode it be explosive if you
take something on c4 it would be
explosive so I play rook to you on he
plays Knight e4 initiating trades takes
takes my plane I left four and then he
played rook g1 check teeny - and then he
traded after the game Lenderman showed
like this insane idea for luck to play
this
let's see if anyone in the chat can find
it this is not easy though black to move
play the best move it's kind of a one
mover though like if you find the first
move
it's essentially the the key thing to
see and then that everything flows after
that so black to move so yeah
congratulations to cheesy puns
the only person suggesting rookie three
asking destroy key three work yeah
rookie three is so strong here because
if I take then he takes and I lose
exchange and if I take here then he
takes here hitting this and this and if
this and there's just this and takes and
blocks up a piece and if I think the
only move to survive is work h3 but then
there's takes takes in here and he ups
here and he wins this thing so it would
be slightly unfortunate if he found that
but you didn't find that he took on do
you want it's still looking really good
for black and two connected passwords
Bishop which can solidify itself on one
of these squares but I didn't give up I
continued I put the knight on a decent
square I played this move threatening
all these sorts of Forks threatening
actually a lot of Forks here like look
at all these arrows such nice geometry
so thing when so many pieces are on like
the same color square then the knight
has a lot more fork potential
so Bishop c5 defending against all the
forks king c2 at 695 yada yada okay so I
start pushing my pawn actually when I
play Knight d5 I'm threatening to do
this because if takes I I would win the
bishop so yeah he correctly I think
moved the bishop to the desk where he
file and I put the pawn in b5 and this
is where things got tricky because it's
not easy to advance these pawns because
they can't advance like together like
it's very hard for black average to play
f5 so he starts with g4 and then King
here and still f5 usually runs into 97
so I play King d3 qg5 King e4 rook c8
check here move back so it looks like
black is making progress
you played g3 and when he played g3 he
offered me a draw because a draw would
guarantee him clear first and looked
like he was getting a little bit nervous
and then I was trying to decide like do
I is there any way to play on for a win
because usually when someone offers you
a draw it means maybe they're scared but
I realized okay there's no way I can win
this position I mean this pawn is so
close to queening if I were to play on I
would have played Knight takes f6
threatening mates but apparently 9 t
xf64 er then he has Bishop f4 blocks
actually winning here so what ended up
actually happening he offered me other
draw I thought for maybe a couple
minutes and by that time I had less than
two minutes on the clock and then I just
agreed to a draw so I think I was very
fortunate and then we were both happy
like I survived a really bad position
and he won tournaments clear for
so yeah after the game lunderman was
saying night g2s move stopping or a
night III is the best move stopping
apology too and it's actually very
difficult for luck to make progress here
if King h3 then checkmate and it's hard
for this rook to get active because it
always has to watch the b-pawn and I
have ideas that bring my King to f3 so
it was an interesting finish like I
thought I was just gonna lose but then
like the knight was sufficient enough
was nice outpost the king the knight
that rook they all coordinated so that
was end to the tournament had some nice
dinner I want to show flicker yeah I
want to show pictures on Flickr but I
think it's just down yeah the panda a
panda is still here if you guys um maybe
check tomorrow or for the people
watching in the future on YouTube I'll
leave a link in the video description to
the Flickr album of the tournament you
can see many photos from this game you
can also see I'll leave another link to
the YouTube broadcast because they they
have a whole production Lenderman was
giving very nice commentary along with
Ben Simon and they had the robo can so
you could see us like play live and yeah
I was interesting probably go back and
watch some of the commentary and then
they interviewed both of us after the
game too so that wraps up the tournament
had a really good dinner last night's
nice Italian food
then played some bughouse yeah the
broadcast is recorded on the st. Louis
Chess Club YouTube channel have to go to
st. Louis norm Congress round 9 so
thanks people for subbing I'll read off
the names in a moment but also thank you
YouTube people watching in the future
for watching I'll see you guys later
press the subscribe button
or smash it maybe smashing it would be
more effective